[Music]
you've seen this gift
the ending of slumdog millionaire
and
um
okay look i'm american and i've never
seen a full indian film in my entire
life
but that all has to change now that i've
witnessed
r
r
r
scrapped again for writer director ss
rajamouli's epic historical action
musical that proves beyond a shadow of a
doubt that american movies would be 10
times better if vin diesel and the rock
could do this
[Music]
i don't think so
where instead of using vfx to cut down
on costs they use it to make their stars
do the impossible
and pack in so much animal mayhem
they had to put freaking oxen in the
disclaimer oxen look out
he brought a zoo
[Music]
follow the story of two real historical
figures though i'm pretty sure they
never did this together
raju is a delhi police officer who's
always hot
bean is a jungle warrior who's always
wet when fate makes them all hot and wet
together their bond grows so powerful it
transcends words
as these two brothers-in-arms speak the
universal language of beatdowns
[Music]
dance battles
and casual horse versus motorcycle beach
racing that's just something they do in
an hour friends montage it's not even
part of the plot
just beautiful stuff man
delve into a history and culture you
probably have zero non-racist references
for but you've seen enough michael bay
movies to wonder am i watching
propaganda right now this looks like
captain america's uso show but whatever
they're selling to indians one message
is clear to the entire world
seriously
the british as the brits range from evil
[Music]
to demonic i want to see his neck drawn
out tight
and his eyes bulge and pop
just before his neck
snaps to holy sh that woman carries a
spiked whip between her legs just in
case someone needs torturing aren't you
quite
vicious my dear in a portrayal that's so
negative it got an actual englishman to
pin a rebuttal of mild annoyance my word
what an off-putting display
indeed
settle in for a three-hour run time so
there's room for action dancing singing
comedy politics and romance
none between the leads but yeah there's
definitely some tension there
like the romance between raju and sida a
girl who waited four years for her man
to pick up something from the store
[Music]
and the romance between beam and jenny a
story of how true love overcomes all
even not knowing a single word the other
person's saying i'm sorry i can't
understand what you're saying sorry oh i
wish i knew what you were saying i'm
sorry jenny
johnny oh i'm rooting for these two just
be careful about the in-laws
so strap in for the year's most
eye-popping crowd-pleasing spectacle
that brings a joy to action filmmaking
not seen since steven chow or james
cameron that will have even the most
jaded hollywood moviegoer dancing in the
isles and rushing to catch up on at
least 50 years of tally in bollywood
films to see what they've missed
happy diwali folks
i think i'm gonna like it here
starring
raj against the machine
brit rule can melt steel beings
the village people
jenae
punisher colonial war zone elsa from the
last crusade i did not see that coming
and summoning all your strength like a
dang dbz character
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bff
[Music]
can we import this movie stunt
coordinator to fix superhero flicks over
here and not just because he's great
because his name is king solomon
you